bradley beal he and westbrook have each  gone  with 30-plus tonight deal with caruso on  him  trying to shake him here he goes beal  yes  big bucket for bradley beal wizards back  up four  saw the whistle there they're going to  put a few a second plus back on the  clock boy bradley beal  man clutch  but great move and concentration and  then  getting into the paint coming up clutch  they do have a timeout if they get  possession back they can't advance it  there's verton's  finishes at the rim a chance in a  three-point play  whoever caught the ball westbrook got it  to protons  and instead of settling he attacked  anticipated the foul  great concentration westbrook  six for 11 tonight from the free throw  line but what a smart play right here  whoever caught the ball  westbrook got it to protons and instead  of settling he attacked  anticipated the foul great concentration